Eric swalwell
the the Former Future president The Man
Who Would have been president if he
wasn't one of the first people to drop
out of the 2020 Democratic primary Eric
swalwell
who infamously seems to have slept with
a Chinese spy Eric swalwell
thinks it's insane that you want to have
a say over your kids education Eric's
walwell tweeted out yesterday
this was in response to Tim Scott
Republican senator saying that we're
putting parents back in charge of their
kids education he says please tell me
what I'm missing here what are we doing
next putting patients in charge of their
own surgeries clients in charge of their
own trials when did we stop trusting
experts period by the way he didn't have
a question mark at the end of that
question just a period
that's from expert Eric swalwell this is
so stupid
so just
in point of fact
patients are generally in charge of
their own Medical Care
that they go out and they hire a doctor
they go and they find they consult and
they get different opinions and they say
okay maybe I'll have this surgery maybe
I'll have this procedure and clients
generally are in charge of their own
legal representation
they hire a lawyer or they represent
themselves but they're the ones
ultimately in charge
but this is what they think of you
this is what they think they think that
not only do you not have the right to
your
sit right to keep and bear arms not only
do you not have the right to free speech
not only do you not have the right to
make your views known in the Public
Square not you don't even have a right
to raise your kids
education means
raising raising up means leading Out
means
it's not just reading writing and
arithmetic it's the whole process of
forming a person of leading them come
that comes from the the root for leading
and what Eric swallow is saying is you
don't have the right to any say in that
we do I do I Eric swalwell who doesn't
know how to use question marks I Eric
swalwell I'm going to educate your
children
tell me what I'm missing here
if you don't have the right
some right
to educate your children
you don't have any rights
okay now that's not to say that you have
the sole right to educate your children
this I think is where conservatives go a
little too far this is where actually
Hillary
makes a point at least in the title she
chose for one of her books even though
she is perverting and misusing the
aphorism that she is borrowing
it does in fact take a village to raise
a child
children are not only educated by Mommy
and Daddy children inevitably are
educated by their Community that's just
what happened kids are just sponges they
take in everything if something's on the
TV that's going to be educating your
kids
if if they're hearing something from
their friends in the neighborhood that's
going to educate the kids
if they're paying any attention
whatsoever in school
that's going to educate your kids kids
are just
sucking in information and behaviors and
a moral View and a whole perspective on
the world all right and so
we need to defend our right as parents
to have some choice in the matter but
that's not enough we actually have to go
further and wield political power as
people like lanyonkin and especially
Rhonda Santos have done wheel that
political power to
force a certain type of education on the
political Community we have to force it
we have to coerce it I know that
conservatives sometimes are afraid of
using those words but all education is
coercive it that's what education is
when when the teacher says Johnny do
your homework or you get a bad grade
Johnny repeat after me you know the the
American Revolution began in 1776 and
that's a fact you have to repeat that
fact and if you don't repeat that fact
then you're going to get detention
education is coercive it has to be and
there's it's a paradoxical because the
purpose of education is to liberate
oneself from the base passions and from
our sort of
slavishness that we're born into in this
world of sin and death and to bring our
base appetites under a line and into a
cord with our rational will and to to
this is why we call it the liberal arts
right to make sense of our freedom and
to use it in a way that is edifying and
not debasing and not licentious so
that's the purpose of it but in order to
do that we have to be coerced and
there's only so much time in a classroom
and there are only so many days in the
school year and so you've got to make
choices about what to teach every minute
that you're teaching Maya kababi
genderqueer you are not teaching
Shakespeare or civics or the Bible I
guess we're not allowed to teach the
Bible anymore or anything else that
would be edifying so you've got to say
no Maya kababi no genderqueer no
critical race Theory we are Banning that
from the classroom we are wielding the
power of the state to coerce that out of
the classroom yes to Shakespeare and
math and science
and true history and all the rest of it
we have to do that now private lives yes
in our political lives as well the
Republicans who get that are the ones
who are going to be successful right now
head on over to goodranchers.com Knowles
you know I love spending the holidays
with my family and one of the ways I
like to do that is with delicious meat
from good ranchers as a special gift to
our listeners this holiday season good
ranchers is giving away two Black Angus
New York strip steaks free with your
order these are two 12 ounce Steakhouse
quality Cuts that's a 70 value for free
you don't want to miss this offer let me
tell you why Black Angus tastes better
and is more tender than any other beef
black angus meat is marbled in such a
way that the fat is distributed thinly
and evenly this marbling gives it a
consistent flavor that you don't get
with other meats plus the Black Angus
from good ranchers is hand cut and
trimmed by expert butchers so you know
every piece is going to be Exquisite
while grocery store meat prices are on
the rise good ranchers is dedicated to
helping you save as much as possible if
you subscribe to good ranchers today you
can lock in your price and avoid these
insanely high prices at the grocery
store and get some free meat while
you're at it go to goodranches.com
Knowles use code Knolls at checkout for
this special offer that is
goodranchers.com Knowles for two Black
Angus New York strip steaks with your
order for free good ranchers American
Meat delivered hey Michael my name's
John big fan of the show listen every
day um I have a question I'm a Bible
believing Christian not a Catholic but a
Christian I hope you can forgive me and
welcome me in but um we talk a lot about
god-given rights on the on the right
especially we really like to cite those
as a means for policy and and whatever
else that follows but I'm just
struggling with the idea of what our
god-given rights where do they come from
where do we learn where they are it's
obviously not a very effective argument
to use against someone who doesn't
believe in God but aside from that
um I don't see anywhere in the Bible
that it says God gives you these rights
and if someone violates them this
happens maybe I'm missing it maybe it's
interpretation based but I just want to
think about your thoughts on that I
think it's very interesting conversation
that nobody seems to have despite
everybody always citing human rights
when they want to get things done a
certain way thanks a lot certainly is
very interesting you'll notice that I
don't use that language very much it is
true
many probably most conservative
public figures
prattle on and on and on about god-given
rights left to right and the libs talk
about human rights left and right
because they don't believe in God
but I don't really use that language
because
that language comes largely out of the
Enlightenment and comes largely out of
the early days of liberalism and you you
say you know things that are called
god-given rights I don't really see them
popping up in the Bible or in the
Christian tradition and that that's true
I I asked
or I I forget if it was me or a friend
of mine got to see we both got to see
Scalia when we were students and one of
us asked Scalia
do you believe in natural rights so
important to certainly at that time the
way that conservatives were talking
about the country do you believe in
natural rights and he said I believe in
the natural law
because the idea of
politics from the perspective of Rights
whether they be positive rights or
negative rights human rights or
god-given rights but the the whole idea
of politics from the perspective of
Rights is a liberal idea it's not a very
conservative idea the conservative
perspective is politics from the
perspective of Duty and obligation and
tradition and wisdom and Justice and
prudence
and so I think it would be much more and
I agree with you also just as a
practical matter those phrases are not
particularly persuasive we can go on and
on all day and say well I've got a
god-given right to free speech
whatever that means I don't even know
really what that means or the lips can
say I've got a human right to
I don't know chop off all my genitals
and make you pay for it and dye my hair
purple and do whatever you know but it
doesn't that doesn't really persuade
anybody the natural law however is
different because the natural law
from which we derive a concept of
natural rights but the natural law is
just the the moral reality that we can
perceive through the use of our natural
reason and our moral conscience and that
that is much more persuasive because
people know that it's wrong to commit
murder wherever you go doesn't matter if
they've read the Bible people just know
it's wrong to commit murder we know we
know that certain behaviors are just
wrong we have a kind of wisdom of
repugnance we have a a moral conscience
with which we are mercifully endowed and
so I think that perspective is going to
be much more persuasive the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it okay because this is fake
headline Friday if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]